the year 1975 the problem cars are using
too much gas the solution improve
average fuel economy by penalizing
automakers who fail to meet efficiency
standards categorized by vehicle size
creating more stringent targets for
passenger cars than for trucks used in
farmwork and Commercial hauling sounds
like a great idea with the best of
intentions what could possibly go wrong
turns out car manufacturers don't like
paying fines in order to comply with the
new rules autom began making their cars
bigger voila more crossovers SUVs and
minivans all of which technically meet
the government definition of a light
truck that's why this Lexus NX is
actually considered a truck so is this
Rav 4 and this Subaru Outback in fact
light trucks now account for almost 80%
of all new vehicles sold wait to truck
things up